Hey, what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
May 30th, 2016. How are
you? How's it going?
Oh Wow.
Oh look at show. What do you
do from Memorial Day? Yeah,
yeah. It's, you fill up the above ground
pool or God bless Ya. Go. I bless you.
I'll be over with a couple of hours.
You know what I've been
drinking late, Stacy.
Stacy, Stacy, Stacy.
Yeah. Over here. You know
what? I paid tricking lately.
I don't know why I started drinking
the cause light again. I remember them.
Silver Bullets fucking prom night.
Um, how many did you get in your class
of Jesus Christ? Um, Happy
Memorial Day. Everybody.
Thank you to everybody in the military
for doing what it is that you do.
Um, so that morons like me can run
their fucking yaps and not, uh,
have a black van pull up and
take me away to get reeducated.
Um, that's it. Happy, happy,
happy day off on a Monday.
They should have one of these
a fucking month. You know,
they should have one three
day weekend a month. If,
if Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders
would get on board with that,
the two candidates that the people want,
people want to vote for either one
of them too, and they're gonna Ramel,
Hillary, right down. You're fuck
El Cuckoo clock face herself.
Write down your fucking
throat. That's what they're gonna
do. I watched this clip on Facebook,
so you know, it had to be true
were Chris Matthews right?
Was basically just mind fucking everybody
saying that Hillary was gonna win it
and blah blah blah, blah, blah.
Just say when she wins it and all that
type of shit and she wasn't doing like a,
he wasn't doing like a dude I called
the type of thing. He's just doing that.
Like the rich, the rich liberals,
you know those ones, y'all, the ones who
act like they care about anybody else,
they actually, they,
they're worse than rich
Republicans because Republicans
don't act like they give
a fuck about other people.
But rich liberals, AH,
they're the fucking worst
bleeding heart, you know,
caring about everybody in their
fucking gated communities.
Oh Jesus, pill the fuck
did you have for breakfast?
What did I have for breakfast? Say
Two eggs way g two eggs over easy.
And I always buy these eggs from this
fucking Lilly's farm because it sounds
like it's some chick down the street who
just has a hen house and she's making
them from my neighborhood. But God, no,
she knows some giant corporation and I
dunno what the fuck they're doing with
these eggs.
They have the thinnest slash
hardest egg shells ever.
So if you tap real lightly poop
in the bottom of the fucking pad,
they will not break. And
if you get them this, this,
this one fucking sweet
spot that you hit the,
you hit the fucking egg shell, that will
actually crack and it won't break yolk.
All
right. I don't know if you guys
know about this, know this about me,
but I do not break egg yolks. Okay.
And I'm also superstitious when
it comes to breaking egg yolks.
I feel like if you break the fucking Yolk,
that means your day is going
to be a shit show, right?
It's a metaphor. You had a plan
and the whole thing went to shit.
And then you got a scramble it up.
Right. That's how I look at it.
So not only did I break, I broke one,
the other one was okay,
but then I was just so fucking frustrated
because you want them runny cause then
you still have the
nutrition in there. Right.
All these people to have it
over hard. Yeah. Over hard.
Like you're fucking
arteries. Right. So, uh,
I go to flip the thing and I'm so fucking
frustrated that it's gonna turn into
basically a fried egg sandwich. I got
mad and I go to flip the other one.
I broke that one too. I just was in
my kitchen by myself going, yeah,
there you go. Fuck the whole thing,
right? Yeah. Fuck the whole thing.
The nini downstairs. Are you all
right? Yeah. Fine. What are you doing?
Oh, just making some eggs,
honey. Does it sound like it?
Okay. I, I've to interrogation, right?
It comes to fucking interrogation.
Like Norbert Leo Butz,
his wife on bloodline.
Oh my God. That character is
driving me up the fucking wall.
Not saying the actress, she's phenomenal.
But that whole dynamic, it's like,
can you just shut up? Can
you leave the man alone?
Is anybody watching bloodline? I'm not
going to ruin any of this shit, but a,
you got to fucking watch it. You
got to watch it. I'm like, uh,
I'm already five episodes into season
two. What just came out? Um, you know,
I had a nice three day weekend, so Billy
fucking, ah, red cakes here. I, um,
I've been fucking Netflix the whole
weekend. Started off the weekend.
I watched the do over
Adam San Louis new movie with
David Spade. It was fucking great.
I always loved Sandler's fucking movies
and uh, I love spades character. I,
that's hard to talk about a movie
without saying what the fuck happens.
Just watch it. And also just being a fan
of people out here in Hollywood that,
that do their own goddamn thing. Um,
I guess Sandler's movies crush
it on Netflix. So he's like,
but why fucking take it to the movie
theater? I'll just take it right to you.
So we cut a deal with them for like his
next, I don't know, four to six movies.
And they went right right to that. So I
believe this is the first one and I'm,
I fucking loved it man. I love it.
I got a, I can't say what happens,
but there was this one thing
that Sandler did and I was like,
that's probably gonna be the most
disgusting thing I'm going to see for the
first half of the year.
And then something else happens that
involves a fucking old lady. Um,
so there you go. I just primed the
pump, check it out if you get a chance.
And I been watching
bloodline and then, uh,
somebody else recommended I am
road comic and it was about, uh,
just these comics, Wayne Fetterman and
these guys doing this road gig and uh,
enjoyed all of that,
enjoyed all of that. And uh,
but I mentioned earlier that, uh, check
those out if you can't check them out,
if you can. Anyways,
so I mentioned earlier that I am in a
much more upbeat mood than I have been in
a while. You know, and I know what you
think of bill. Oh, wait, what'd you,
what'd you get another bottle of
booze? No, not at all. Not at all.
I finally went to a chiropractor.
All right.
I went to a chiropractor. Um, and
I never, I never go to the doctor.
All right? Because that's how I was
brought up. Christ, I'm telling you,
believe Christ,
you're going to get down here and you're
gonna fight going to charge you up the
fucking wide zone. Let's take
a God damn aspirin. All right.
You hang from a pull up bar,
you'll be fine. All right.
I came from a family and a time where
you didn't go to the fucking doctor.
If you went to the fucking,
you don't go to the doctor.
You don't take your car to a mechanic
cause they're going to fucking find
something. So I finally go
to the chiropractor because
at this point I told you,
I'm literally in the writers room.
I have cushions from this couch
on the floor and I'm, I'm,
I lay on the floor and uh,
I call it floor pitching.
I just pitched jokes laying on the floor.
And then when it gets to some
critical part of the story,
I then stand up to see what's going
on and then I laid back down again.
Then I just lay in the ground. What if,
uh, what if Frank said, uh, you know,
I'll put you through the fucking
wall. Right? That's what I do.
So I finally couldn't take it anymore
and a buddy of mine who works on the show
said I got a great chiropractor. And I
finally was just like, you know what?
You've got to let that fucking suburban
Boston shit go. Okay. There's no way.
If they always fucked up, everybody
would still be going to them.
So I ended up going down there
and this guy was a fucking wizard.
Unbelievable. Right?
He literally like put his hand right in
my lower back and was just pushing on my
spine. Like on one side of it, it was
going on. It seems like you have a, a,
an older injury here from a long
time ago. And I was like, yeah,
how the fuck did you know
that? Because now I can tell,
cause this is bold j like I had a
bulging disc and he goes, hey, I go,
yeah fucking I one of my,
when I was in fourth grade,
you know,
I was into wrestling and the buddy of
mine knew how to do the figure four leg
lock.
And unfortunately the only way to teach
someone how to do it is to put him in
it. And he put me in the fucking thing.
And when I sat up to
try to free my leg, I I,
that was the first time I felt a something
go out in my back and then the next
time was playing football freshman
year of high school pickup football.
I didn't play organized,
didn't play organized cause I got a d
in math in fifth grade and that was,
that was, that was my retirement.
Like when Jordan retired in 2003,
except by now I won one
championship and I never returned.
Um,
okay.
But anyways, he was able
to fix all of that shit.
I immediately felt better the next day
I was sore. And then over the weekend,
like, um, like last night for the
first time in like two months,
I was able to sit down for a significant
period of time and have no pain
whatsoever. And uh, I just
been doing all these stretches.
And, uh, the biggest one is
I've been doing, uh, that,
you know, the up dog yoga
stretch for your a was your,
so as muscle in the front, I just thought
it connected your top to your bottom,
just where your hips were and it
ran perpendicular to your waist.
I didn't realize that it came up and
then Kinda made like an s turn right to
like the middle of your body. He was
explaining to me, I forget what it is,
but like I've been stretching that thing
and do what my Vietnamese gambler squat
and a couple of runners stretch. And uh,
I think by this time next week I should
be, I should be right as rain. And um,
okay
dude, he fucking crack my back.
I didn't know he was gonna do it.
I was laying on my back and he goes,
all right, bring your knees up.
Bring them over to the side.
Just let it relax. Relax.
Let me have all the weight
and fucking right there, Fred.
And I just started fucking
laughing like, dude, what the fuck?
Cause I always thought it was like
they were cracking your bones.
I guess there's gas that they're releasing
in there. I have no fucking idea.
But anyways.
MMM [inaudible]
I dunno, I, I,
that's something I always have to
remember that just because something's a
racket doesn't mean that there's not
somebody that's really good at it.
You know what I mean? Like think of
the reputation that comedians have.
We don't have a good reputation. We're
on offstage where attention whores,
we got the fucking lamp shades on our
head and we tell fucking awful jokes. Yet,
despite that, there's still
your fucking, you know,
David Tells Chappelle's Louis C
K's and all of those fucking guys.
Um,
okay.
So that's what I guess what you gotta do.
You got to find the Louis C K of
chiropractice before you fucking go in.
And I think I did. So,
um,
I dunno, this is so I don't even
know how to get out of this.
It was just something good happened to
me and I told you the story and nothing
bad happened so I don't have any jokes
about it other than I couldn't find the
fucking place. You know, I was
driving over with my phone. Right.
It's directing me over there and
then in the last second, okay.
Um,
right when I needed it, where the
building was, I hit like a whatever,
a dead zone and I had nothing.
Um,
and I walked up to the building
was one of those partially
like rented buildings.
So it looked like it was abandoned from
where I was and I'm looking in and up by
now I'm already losing
my shit. I'm like, wait,
this nobody even fucking built
fucking buildings offended.
Then I just see this nurse work by
looking at me with their scrubs on like,
what the fuck is your problem? It's
just an, I had to kind of be like,
play it off and then kind
of follow her around the,
the part of the building
that was actually being used.
I swear to God, man, I need to
learn how to have patience. I just,
uh, I have zero fucking patients.
I have zero fucking tolerance,
all of that shit. And um, I dunno.
It's really going to be the death of me.
I really got to learn to just fucking
relax. It's weird little shit.
Little Shit fucking drives me up the wall.
Major shit or major pains in the ass.
I just laugh and I, okay. Yesterday I
was driving my lovely wife back from,
went over to the mall. She
picked up a few things.
We got all the way home by back,
was starting to kill me and she realized
she left one of her shopping bags and
I'm in a store and she flipped the fuck
out and it just, and I was like, oh no,
it's fine. It's fine. Okay.
I don't give a shit. Right.
I drive all the way back. My back's
killing me. I didn't give a fuck.
Totally relaxed. That was fine, right?
But then like an old lady walks in a
crosswalk and I have to wait an extra six
seconds to make a left. And I literally
have a meltdown for the life of me.
I can't figure out why that
is. Um, but anyways, um,
speaking of great standup Comedians, um,
Doug, Stan hope put something up.
He wrote something,
he's friends with Johnny Depp and he's
going through this brutal fucking divorce
and uh,
I just want to give him props for sticking
up for his friend and everything and
saying something. Cause you know,
you know what's really so fucked up.
All right?
It's all this shit that happens to
women that guys do. Women is fucked up.
But there has been a slight
overcorrection now where if somebody's,
a woman just says, you do something
before you're ever tried or convicted,
it just gets put in the paper.
It gets put all over the Internet
and then all you fucking moron.
So 90% of you on the fucking
Internet, just take it as truth.
Take it as fun. Why do
you take it as truth?
Because you want it to be true cause
he's doing better than you in life.
I mean it's fucking unbelievable.
I really believe this. Okay.
If somebody gets accused,
okay,
okay. Of, of, of rape
or domestic violence,
they should not publicize the person's
name until they're convicted of it.
I think that's more than fair considering
all the fucking dopes out there that
the second day read something Trump,
you know,
let it fucking see what happens first.
See what the fuck happens first.
All that, that, that whole thing.
Now that all you gotta do is just say it.
The amount of fucking guys who have
been falsely accused of that shit.
It's like you literally fucking
with their ability to get a job,
you fucking with your reputation
and you know the deal dude,
like domestic violence and anything
involving sex, that shit never goes,
that never goes away.
Um,
so I dunno, I just want to, you know,
give Stan hope fucking props are
actually sticking up for the guy.
Cause there's a lot of people, you
know, because of the stigma around that,
even if they know it isn't true,
they're afraid to throw their hat
in the fucking ring right now.
I don't know what the fuck
happened or whatever. Okay.
I am just saying the fact that
somebody finally just said, hey,
this guy hasn't been tried for
anything yet. He's a friend of mine.
I know he would never do this. It was,
it was refreshing to finally read
that and for somebody to finally say,
you know what I believe is you shouldn't
put somebody's name out there until,
you know, 100% tried and convicted.
They definitely did that shit.
And then if they did tar and feather
them, but to do that to somebody,
um,
and also to give that weapon to somebody
that they can just fucking say that and
blackmail you with that and, and
really destroy your reputation.
Um,
I don't know. It's fucking reprehensible.
So this or there's another thing
that isn't really funny, you know,
you know, it's like all those
Duke lacrosse players, this shit,
they just fucking faces all
over the fucking, and you know,
to this day, despite the fact
that they were totally vindicated,
despite the fact that there was the 30
for 30 talking about how bad they got
railroaded despite all of that, you know,
that still going to affect
their lives. You know,
there's still going to be somebody
going, yeah, but you know,
something happened. You know,
somebody when they get mad and
they got nothing else to say,
they're going to call him a
rapist or something like that.
You fucking know that they're
gunna. Um, so I dunno.
I know it was, it was good to see. And
of course it was stand up, stand up,
stand ups, good fucking man.
Um, um, as is Johnny Depp,
by the way, a few times, he's a, he's a
big standup fan. He comes out to shows,
he's fucking humble as
hell, you know, gentle.
One of the most gentle fucking people
ever. You know what I mean? Look,
listen to me. Listen how the fuck
I talk. You know what I mean?
You don't understand it. If it came,
you know somebody said that about me that
he fucking snap like posey and fucking
dirty dozen. I don't know.
I barely know the guy.
I've only met him a few fucking
times, but like I don't,
I really tend to believe what the Fuck
Stan is saying and I 100% believe that
you should not be putting somebody fucking
name out there just because somebody
said it. You know? Oh it's fucking
I Billy's fucking state is brutal.
She's going for fucking
spousal support, you know,
going for fucking spouse's support,
which means he's got to pay her for
like the rest of her fucking life.
She married the guy for 15 fucking
months and you're kills me.
Bought that person. She's going to
fucking go to the Beyonce concert. Oh,
the day it is independent and she why
you watch your throw a fucking hand up.
Wow. That shit gets me heated.
Alright, here we go. Here we go.
Is there any fucking ribbons for guys
falsely accused of rape and domestic
violence? You know, do they
get their month? You know,
w w will the NFL wear a color for
them? Of course they want, they aren't,
they don't give a fuck. Um, anyways.
All right, here we go.
Let's talk about, um,
let's talk about that game six.
Holy fucking shit. Game six,
OKC, golden state warriors. And when
I say holy fucking Shit, not only do,
I mean it was a great game.
I mean, holy fucking shit.
You guys are gonna have to sit here
and listen to a man who never watches
basketball. Talk about
basketball. Actually,
I watched the most I've watched this year
and I watched the Celtics mainly. Um,
fucking brutal, man. I W
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I always root for the underdog. So I
was going for OKC, right? And, you know,
Golden State got theirs last
year. I liked, I, you know,
I've been to a home game
of, um, of the thunder.
The fans are fucking unreal.
And I love their stadium.
It's like a college stadium, you know,
it's not like fucking triple decker. Um,
luxury boxes like down the staple
center, which every time I go in there,
there's a part of me that gets really
sad for the, for like true Laker fans,
true king fans, true clipper fans that
they got banished that fucking high up.
It's fucking ridiculous. They got a
Goddamn nightclub in there, you know,
where you can hang out afterwards.
It's the stupidest shit ever. Right.
And meanwhile, all the fucking,
the real fence that had
been hanging out, you know,
the only real fan in the lower level
of at the Lakers game, you got two,
Diane Cannon and Jack Nicholson.
They'd been there for fucking ever.
And I think it was Jack
First. Um, but anyways,
uh, and I, I, I've seen,
I saw Kevin Duran play
when he was still, uh,
senate key arena when he's still with
the sonics. And I was at that game when,
uh, OKC was playing, um, the Miami
Heat and Chris Bosh Gotten in, uh,
one of the, uh, thunders
guys' faces. And, uh,
Duran immediately walked over and
said some shit and broke it up.
And then he like was really
fucking, you know, look like,
not yelling but just laying down the lot.
It was teammate and afterwards they
asked him what he said. He said,
I just told them there's a lot of phony
tough guys in the league and that guy's
one of them. And right there, I mean,
he was like 2123 when he did it,
I was like, yeah, you got it. You
can't not love that guy. Right?
So I'm rooting for these guys and I'm,
it's the classic fucking thing about a
team that knows how to win another one
that didn't, they had
those funds. They actually,
they actually won the fucking game. They
had the fuck. I can't say they weren't,
they hadn't won.
They were up by seven with four and a
half minutes left and they were playing
like they were down by 15
and fucking the warriors,
they will like, they will
like this patient. Like,
you know when you see like I want a python
grabbed something and it wraps itself
around you and it just chill it.
And every time you s s exhale,
it just fucking goes a little tighter
and a little tighter, you know,
and then you're like, you can't fucking
breathe. You pass out and it's over.
That's all they did. If you
won't rewatch that game,
they never increased the tempo
or their game. They just fucking,
they would like Jason and Friday that
13th you know when someone's running away,
oh, Casey was a victim running
away, looking over their shoulder.
So they're tripping over logs and shit
and they just fucking walked up on them.
And that was it. Fucking
machete to the back of the neck.
They were playing like they went down by
15 when they were up by seven and then
they just started coming down the court.
They stopped passing the fucking
ball and Josh [inaudible], that was,
that was one of the most
devastating losses I've seen of,
of a home team in a long fucking time.
They just ripped their hearts out,
fucking held it up to their faces
and then threw it into the crowd.
There was dead fucking
silence except for those 20,
unbelievable stereotypical jerk off
California sports fans that hung around.
They are the fucking worst. Not
all of them, but 80% of them.
They are the fucking way.
Maybe there was a touch of the Yolo
Douche that was fucking going on, right.
You know the white guys with the hat to
the side and you know, two of them DJ,
right? Um, they were
standing behind our, uh,
all of the, uh,
all of the fucking announces they're
near killed me when we were watching it.
She was fucking making
fun of shack. He said he,
she said he's wearing this big
blue suit, this big round head.
She said he looked like
one of those talking mnms.
Um, anyways, but Jesus
Christ, Clay Thompson, my God,
at what point are you
going to cover the guy?
This is what's so fucked up about
the NBA. You know, when, uh,
when, when or whatever
it was, fuck his name.
When Steph curry goes down the lane
for like the 50th fucking time,
he looked cross over here,
a little Dan will pop do,
and he's in the air back in
the day that you would've got,
you would've got fucking brought down
to earth on the back of your head.
That would've been it.
And everyone would've stood up and
pushed and shoved and nobody would've got
objected. He's fucking
like, that's something,
because I watched very little basketball
for a long time during my standup
career and I just cannot believe the
way you can just coast down the fucking
lane. You know what I mean? Back in the
day, if you tried to go down the lane,
you had to be a fucking man. You know,
you knew you were going to at some,
you know, you could get away with it
once, maybe twice. And then that was it.
It was like when Michael Vick was running
around as a quarterback, you know,
eventually one of those linebackers was
going to have an opportunity. And, um,
yeah, it was gonna you know, this, you
know, if you are running quarterback,
you know, eventually, you know,
it's almost like considered like a,
I feel it's considered like
a cheap fucking play. Like
we got you guys covered,
you know what I mean? And then you're
just going to fucking, you know,
run and then fucking slide on your ass
for a first down that makes people mad on
the defense and eventually you're not
going to have time to go down or they
don't give a fuck that you're going down
and they're going to take the fucking
the fine.
And I'm amazed how that has been
taken out of the fucking game.
These guys just glide watch. 'Em
Okay.
I, I want to say when Mikael hit Rambis,
I don't even know if there was a foul,
there must've been a foul, but nobody
was objected. That would have been like,
what? I don't know. Whatever
the suspensions are nowadays,
three to five game suspensions. But
anyways, um, Clay Thompson, Jesus Christ,
the fucking guy was unconscious and uh,
I got to tell you, man, I just,
the only reason why I think OKC can win
game seven is nobody thinks they can't.
And that always makes me feel like Vegas
is going to win a ton of fucking money.
I actually have a bet I called
in the a I am Rapaport podcast.
Um,
cause we're at a port anytime anything
bad happens to two fucking Boston teams,
he's just got a hard on for
it. You know what I mean?
And then he tries to act like he
doesn't give a fuck about baseball.
And then when I bring up how successful
the Yankees are, he flips out.
That's right. That's right.
When we fucking prison
rates you, he flips out. It,
it literally ages that man,
what has happened over the
last decade and a half,
what we have accomplished
with only four teams,
even our fucking soccer team, if
you want to throw that in, right?
Even they won a championship. It,
Apple's absolutely fucking
devastates that man, you know?
And all these got his, the two giant
Superbowls, which to be honest with you,
Ian Ho, I don't give a fuck if
you told me 15 years ago, Hey,
the patriots are going to
go to six Superbowls and
when four of us do you think
I'm going to cry about the
other two? I don't give a fuck
four and two, I'll fucking take
that. You know, else would take that,
the fucking giants,
if they could have gone to six and one
for, and why wouldn't you? Uh, well,
you know,
something they would probably say went
into against the Patriots was better.
And I would actually believe that. I
would actually believe that. So whatever,
you know what I mean? But that's
the kind of sports fan I am.
I don't have this blind hatred, you know,
this is the thing, this
is the thing about me,
as much as I sound like I'm
upper deck, I'm really not.
I am the way I drink. I am way I talk
the way I curse. I am an upper deck
guy, but I am a logical son of a bitch.
I'm not saying I'm box seats.
I'm on the mezzanine level. Okay.
I'm just that much closer to
the fucking, to the field.
Now Rapaport Rapaport
is upper deck all day,
all fucking day, and if he hears this,
he's going to say he's
actually proud of it.
Rappaport set guy at the top of the
fucking stadium going, is anybody looking?
Is anybody looking at any fucking
takes a piss up in the corner.
You know what I mean?
He actually really is more like
a Philly fan than a New York fan.
He can't help him. He just can't
help it. The man, the man has an,
and when I hear is hatred towards Boston
sports and when I hear his excitement
every time they reinstate
the Brady suspension,
it just makes me [inaudible]. I gay.
I can't even tell you how happy it makes
me that there's a New York sports fan
that is experiencing this level of joy
that something bad is finally happening
to a Boston team this century.
It never used to be that way.
You know? You know what New York
sports fans are to Boston fans,
they're like your big brother.
That used to be able to could beat
you up until you about 14 and then you
finally kicked his ass,
you know, you know,
throw them down the flight
of stairs. You know,
you felt them quit and it's
fucking over. You know you need it,
but it's never over. Cause
you know, it's some point,
some point in your thirties,
something's going to comment
and something's going to
happen at like a family
reunion and they're gonna come
at your one more time, right?
You just give him the old front face
luck right into a back body drop and then
it's fucking over. Once you hear their
body hit that linoleum floor, right?
The ankle just clips the
counter. That fucking done.
I love Rapaport, you know? All right.
He's another pasty fucking human being
is out of his fucking mind. Just like me.
All right, let's read a
little bit of advertising.
Literally advertising here for a,
and when I say little, I mean little.
We only got to reads everybody. Ah,
when you try to make the reads funny,
there goes the honey right out the fucking
door. All right. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody guys, um,
I slash we really appreciate you
listening to the show and wanted to do
something to thank you who writes this.
So I slash we contacted my slash
our friends@dollarshaveclub.com
and arrange for
them to give new members a month,
a month of the executive razor for free
just for buying a tube of Dr cabbies.
Easy shape. I didn't do this. This is a,
this is a bald faced
lie. I never did this.
I'm slash we're super excited.
They're doing it for you. Listen me,
can I just put it in my own words?
Dollar Shave. Get a great fucking deal.
I'm happy that doing this for
you because when I was your age,
I had to pay through the nose for fucking
expensive fucking razorblades that are
made out of fucking plastic and recycled
coke cans and they charged you like
fucking 25 bucks for a pack.
It's complete horse shit.
Somebody saw the
opportunity to be like, Hey,
what if I didn't make a 900000000%
profit and I just made a fucking hundred
percent profit? Right? This
guy here at dollar shave club.
He's like the Robin Hood of the shaving
industry. All right, here's the deal.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your fucking door for a
third of the price of what the
gree razor corporations charge you.
That means when you
joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. Get first-class
shave when you use the executive blade.
That's without even hurting your wallet
and when you use the executive with
their doctor cavities.
Dr Carver's shave butter.
The blade just gently glides
for the smoothest shave.
Shave butter isn't your
average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling
unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to
join dollar shave club.
I'm drinking the course late. Again,
new members who buy a
tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the
executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this
special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave
club.com/burger that's dollar shave
club.com/bar dollar shave
club.com/bark all right. Oh,
blue apron, everybody. Blue Apron.
What's going on? You're dating.
You got somebody coming over and
you want to cook them a meal,
but you're not confident with your cooking
skills. No worries. Blue aprons here.
All right? Not all ingredients
are created equal, fresh,
high quality ingredients taste
better and are better for you.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Blue Apron knows when you cook
with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals.
So they set the highest quality standards
for their community of artisanal
suppliers, family run farms,
fisheries and ranchers.
How would you investigate
something like that?
This is like some Trump shit where
we have the greatest food ever.
Whether it's Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon
or heirloom tomatoes.
Blue Apron is bringing you the
best for less than $10 per meal.
10 bucks per meal. Come on.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals. Um,
new recipes are created each week by
blue apron culinary team and are not
repeated within a year. That's
fucking crazy. Flexible customers,
your recipes each week are
based on your preferences.
Choose delivery options if it fits your
needs. There is no weekly commitment.
See, you only get
deliveries when you want them. Each
meal comes with the step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes left.
The only way this could be easier is if
they came over and cooked it for you.
Check out this week's menu.
They should have like somebody from blue
man group come over right with the blue
apron. You know, is there
any blue food? Blue potatoes?
I Dunno. Check out this week's
menu and get your two meals free.
Why didn't they do that on breaking bad?
They should had a guy from blue man group
smoking that blue meth and that right
there is why I didn't write
for this show. Alright, free.
All right. By going to
blue apron.com/berg.
You will love how it feels and tastes
to create incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron. Don't wait. That's
blue apron.com/per blue apron.com.
A better way to cook a check out this
weekend's menu and get to two of your
meals for free. For free. That's
right. With free shipping. Sorry,
I forgot that part. All right,
let's get back to the podcast here.
MMM [inaudible]
alright, so ola, oh,
Billy fucking fat cakes.
I'm in a writer's room and I have up
my, blew out my fucking sciatic nerve.
Right?
So I have not been working out and
I've been trying to eat the best I can,
but I finally bit the bullet and stepped
on the fucking scale the other day and
I was one 83 so my fighting weights
one 72 I went down to one 63 last year.
I knew I couldn't sustain that. That
was like my emaciated fucking, you know,
underwear model weight.
But I still, you know, no,
there's never been a redheaded underwear
model. A male one, I don't think,
you know, but there's always a first. Um,
so I really want to be like one
72. So, uh, I just said, you know,
I started yesterday, uh, I got my
birthday coming up on June 10th,
and um,
there cannot be an eight anywhere in
my body weight on my birthday for life.
I've just decided that that's it.
It's not fucking happen. And so, uh,
this morning I was one 81.6, you know,
I got my gym right outside
my back's feeling good.
I'm actually doing fucking legs and
eggs today, right? Legs and eggs.
The foxy lady. Hey guys, come
on down for legs in eggs, right?
I'm fucking doing some squats and um,
okay.
Oh, do the gym is the shit,
the fucking speed bag.
The atomic holds the pegboard.
Um,
I just walked right up.
I want to fucking bench.
I don't have to worry
about anything. You know,
I got a wireless fucking
space, right? I actually don't,
I have this, um, I've
got this other thing,
it looks like a Marshall amp looks
like the head of a Marshall amp.
And you just plug your
phone in there and uh,
and I just crank like fucking ac DC and
fucking all this shit that I love guns
and roses and all that, like
back in the day. And uh,
my goal is one time in my life did I
ever put up to 25 and for four you meet
heads left over from the fucking
eighties to 25 was the shit,
cause that was two 45 pound
plates on both sides. Right.
And you just brought it down
here, right back up again.
And I did that back when I
weighed about a buck 65. So, um,
I am an old man now. So, uh, right
now, you know, I just got the 45,
so on either side, you know, whatever,
I'm working my way back and uh,
I also know how to build myself up without
hurting myself. I always make sure I,
if I'm going to go 20 pounds up,
that I can do 20 pounds less,
at least six times. And then I
just go up and see, you know,
if I can do 20 pounds up
like two times, maybe three.
And I just worked my way up. So, uh,
I literally started out with just
20 fives on either side, you know,
did that 10 times and I threw the 35
10 times and I put the 40 fives on.
I could only do it like six fucking times.
Etic but now I'm back up to 10
reps on all of those. And uh,
I just moved up to a buck 55, which
I put up like four times. So, uh,
I should have my eighties
body back soon. You know,
we had just totally overdeveloped up
top and then I have my chicken legs.
Now it's not happening this time,
this time I'm actually gonna do the
fucking squad, uh, the squats. So, um,
anyways, um, if anybody
else has those atomic holds,
like what are you, cause they
give you those, those little,
those plastic bands that you then put
like the c clamp on and then you can swing
from those things. Like what do
you hook the plastic thing from?
I got them on my chin up bar, but, but
the shitness ceiling is like a fish hook,
but it's totally closed, so I can't
put the plastic thing in there.
I guess I could just fucking email the a,
the company and I could figure out how
to do it. Anyways, let's, let's, uh,
literally babbling here. Oh, who do you
guys like in the Stanley Cup playoffs.
Huh? In the Stanley Cup final. Um,
I gotta tell you after watching
the sharks beat my blues, I have,
uh, nothing but respect
for those guys now. And um,
I actually really liked that team.
Um,
but then I got a ton of
friends in Pittsburgh.
I don't know.
I Dunno. I Dunno what to do. Why
is Sydney Crosby so hateable?
Is it the Pouty Lips?
Was it the crying after every fucking
call for so many fucking years?
The guy's unbelievable. He's unbelievable.
Um,
I dunno, I have no idea
who's going to win that one,
but I'm going to watch partner.
He actually invited me over.
I gotta get back to them. Maybe I'll be
able to run over there and watch this.
And then if I go over there,
I'm not one of those dishes that even
if I wanted San Jose to when I would go
over there and I definitely root
for the pens. Um, you can't,
when you see how happy Joe Barton is,
anytime the penguins score
of fucking goal, there's,
there's no way to not root
for the penguins. And I'm
not even root the penguins.
I'm just rooting
to see Joe Barton or Kathy.
All right, here we go. Um,
s the questions for the
weak, weak, weak, weak,
weak online dating from a lady. Hi,
bumbling Billy butterballs. Hey, I
like that one. Fumbling, rumbling,
bumbling, stumbling. Um,
I actually tweeted a,
you just see that four year old kid fell
into the gorilla and closure and then
they killed the gorillas. Um,
I said a, I tweeted about that.
I was saying how a four
year old does not fall,
accidentally fall into
a gorilla enclosure.
I wrote that was a fun
Hashtag Chris Berman. Uh,
all right.
I am a 26 year old lady
and I met this guy.
I am really into on an online dating app.
I am not on the app for hookups
and don't think he is either.
We have met,
we have met up in public places three
times in the past week and I can really
see potential with them. That's so,
I'm so fucking jealous that you guys
have that app where it's like I'm not on
there just to hook up with people.
Like you literally can turn yourself
into like a Gigolo or a call girl with
regular fucking people.
It's unbelievable. Um,
he said we have met up in public places
three times in the past week and I could
really see potential with him. I haven't
been to his actual apartment yet,
but met him once in the
parking garage of his complex.
That sounds like a blow job. Uh,
sorry. I shouldn't have said that. Oh,
he wants to hang out and watch a
movie at his place. I'm not approved,
naive or getting any weird
vibes or red flags in him.
I just don't want to put myself in any
potentially dangerous situations or give
him any false signs.
How soon is too soon after meeting
someone online to hang out at their
apartment? Dude, what the fuck?
I don't know. I have no idea.
You don't sound comfortable. So I
wouldn't do it. I wouldn't do it. I would,
uh,
I think if you're going to spend time
alone with him for the first time,
I would do it at your place
and have nine one dialed in
the phone in your hand. I mean,
I don't know if you're getting
this kind of a creepy vibe.
Are you getting a creepy vibe
because, um, you met him online?
Um, I, my advice is a,
I would not go over there anytime soon
until that whole fucking vibe goes away.
Um,
and whether you're approved or not
has nothing to do with anything.
That's just, it has to
do with being smart. Um,
Jesus Christ. Now you got me thinking
there's something wrong with them.
You know what? Stay away
from that guy. Um, all right.
Boyfriend doesn't want a dog.
I don't know how to say this.
Hey Billy, is that a French
word? B e t with the little hat
on the first e. Now I
got to look it up. Uh,
you know what happens when I do this
shit. All right. Oh, you know what,
I actually was looking up
the other day, um, cause I'm,
I'm a big fan of the, uh,
83 Philadelphia 70 sixers.
I was looking up a, the, uh,
St Louis Spirits, which was a, um,
an ABA team. French to English
translation. There we go.
It's an ABA team. Oh,
I mean stupid you fucking asshole. Um,
hey Billy, stupid. Um, what was I gonna
say? Uh, I actually looked it up. The,
uh, the St Louis Spirits and um,
they had some of the cool nicknames,
coolest nixed names ever. They had a guy,
bad news, barns, fly Williams
and then Moses, Milan.
Moses didn't even need a
fucking nickname. What, uh,
what this that'd been his real
name? Moses. Moses Malone.
Bad News Barns, fly Williams. And uh,
I watched a, I don't know if there's,
I think there's a 30 for 30 on it. It
seemed like I saw a trailer for it.
Bob Costas was going like, if you
need to know anything about the ABA,
that team was the fucking ABA.
Everything. That was great about it.
And I believe Bob Costas is a Missouri
guy and a so I think that he was doing
all those games. Um, if
I ever meet Bob Costas,
that's the Shit I'm going to ask
him about out of fucking everything.
That's what I would want to talk
to him about is about the a,
the a B a where he got
his start and all that.
You can't fucking believe that. You
know, he got to see all that stuff. Um,
so anyways, here we go. Billy Billy.
Bet Billy. Stupid. All right. Yeah,
yeah. I'm a longtime lady listener.
I love your stand up specials and F
is for family is amazing. Thank you.
A nice work. Thank you. Thanks again.
I'm 29 and I just moved away from Seattle
to San Antonio with my air force pilot
boyfriend. Oh, all right. Uh, what,
how does that, does that one go
off?
We go into the wild blue Yonder de this
is my first time living away from home
and he's gone a lot for work.
I thought it would be a good idea
for us to get a dog to keep me sane.
I love animals and was a part time dog
walker in Seattle. My boyfriend, however,
has never owned a pet in his life and
isn't hot on the idea of having a dog.
He's from Iowa and he believes
livestock should live,
shouldn't live in doors. Oh Jesus.
I've owned cats and dogs
my entire life. In fact,
I had to leave my 17 year old cat
behind in Seattle and it broke my heart.
Can you offer any persuasive words to
help bring him around or should I just
drop it? Thanks for the laugh
and go fuck yourself. Um,
how do you bring them? Well,
you can do it. My wife did.
And you foster air, quote a
rescue dog. That's what happens.
You foster a rescue
dog, which means, yeah,
just have it for the weekend
and as the bit when am I act?
I went from,
there's no fucking way I'm keeping this
dog in an a 48 hour period when all the
way to, oh my God, this
thing's going to die some day.
How am I emotionally going
to be able to handle this?
Um,
you could do that. Um,
I don't listen well this is
what I would do either way,
no matter how this works out,
I would get a small dog. Okay.
Small dogs. Small problems.
Okay. Small expenses,
small shits to pick up as your house
break in the fucking thing. Um,
house training, whatever the
fuck it is. Not a horse bill.
You don't ride the thing. Um,
okay.
How would you do this? Well, it
sounds like he doesn't want to do it.
Why would he call it livestock? It's
not livestock. It's a fucking pet.
Um,
I dunno, you know what it is. This
is the thing. If you foster a dog,
this is what's going to happen.
So this guy grew up on a farm where
he grew up in Iowa. This is the thing,
when you fucking come home on a farm,
a cow's not flipping out and excited
to see you. Neither is a horse.
They can do little things, but nobody
gets excited like a fucking dog.
You know what I mean?
It's like a Dick Vibe,
right? Every time.
Come on,
your dog flips out like you just dunk
the ball on a fast break and the other
team called timeout. That's the
way your dog fucking reacts. Now.
I know from experiences when I was just
a boy and I would walk to school and I
used to feed this horse every day on the
way bill. Was this a Tom Sawyer movie?
No, it isn't.
This was my childhood and I remember
one time it wouldn't come over.
So I walked away and I
fuck on, I looked back,
it was doing that walk or was not in
its head and flipping out for whatever
fucking reason. It was like playing
hard to get. So I know that they can,
I guess on some level show a certain
level of emotion, but like, um,
I think maybe I'm, I
dunno what kind of dog,
if you get a little dog that has
a nice mushed up face, you know,
um,
maybe like one of those French bulldogs
something that snores and farts and you,
your boyfriend can find it funny. I
have no idea. Um, maybe a dog like that,
but uh,
okay.
I, I'd find it hard to fucking believe
unless he grew up on a farm and everybody
grew up on a fucking farm on
a certain level, like date,
they got this cold bloodedness
to them. You know what I mean?
They've just seen too much. They've
seen fucking animals slaughtered,
you know?
Okay.
You know, like when they
were a kid like did dad goes,
you want chicken for dinner? Is that
what you want? [inaudible] crying.
You won't chicken for dinner. All right.
He come out here, you come out of Iraq,
come on out. Which ones is going
to be dad? I don't want chicken.
No. You said you want a
chicken a pick one app.
Okay,
boy, if you don't fucking, I'm going to
fucking have you per day interview one.
Then he fucking just grabs it,
puts it on the chopping block.
Then hands that kid the fucking
Klaver go out and do it.
I sat down, right. They lived through
that. It'd like the age is six,
so they don't look at animals the way
we do and I gotta be honest with you.
I remember one time I saw this guy shoot
a fucking cow cause it was bullying the
other fuck it. And it was shot a stear
cause it was bullying the other steer.
They couldn't figure out why
the, you know, you know, they,
they did come back, you know,
the next morning and like two or
three cows look like they fucking,
somebody tried to do a scrap, extrapolate
some fucking information from them.
Right. Is that the right word? I don't
know. But they got slapped around,
you know,
like they walked into a door and they
couldn't figure what the fuck slapping the
shit out of these stare and it turned,
they figured out which one it was.
So they were like, all right, we
got to kill this fucking thing.
But here's the deal.
We don't want the thing to be stressed
before it's killed because that'll affect
the taste of the meat.
So what they do is they just
sort hook do Buddha, Buddha,
they just sort of pan it
in and yeah, you know,
how you doing? Do p two p two and then
they just fucking take out a gun plan.
They fucking kill it, right? And I
was like, oh my God. So then they,
the guy had like this fucking this
tractor and they tied up the back things,
the back of its legs,
they tied up its back legs and then
they just lifted it up off the ground.
Then they gutted the fucking
thing. All the blood's pouring out,
all the fucking end trails. And I'm
just sitting there going, oh my God,
I'm never eaten meat again.
This is fucking horrific. Right?
And then they, once they fucking chop
the head and the legs off and they get,
they get the firth the hide off and
they started chopping it up out.
I went from like, Oh my God,
I'm never eating meat again to my
mouth watering going, holy fuck.
Look at all those steaks.
And this guy was cutting them
in like four inch fucking slabs,
like Fred Flintstone fucking
steaks. And it's just like, dude,
you could literally eat yourself to death
and not get a third of the way through
that fucking cow cattle or what a
steer, whatever the fuck it is. Um,
so I think the thing about it
is, is if he grew up in Iowa,
anywhere near a farm, that's how they
look at animals. They look at it like,
you know,
this is a food source and a don't
get too emotionally attached to it.
Keep it outside.
Do not give it a fucking name and
when it can't make you any more money,
you give it the old fucking right
there Fred. So he might be a loss cost,
you know what I mean? And as
bad as that might be for you,
I got to tell you like the fact that
he can off those feelings like that is
great if he ever have an intruder
because God help him when that guy,
when the intruder gets
those farmhands around them
fucking throwing bales, they
hay since he was four years,
it could farm boys strength,
Jesus Christ, that fucking,
all those fucking,
every offensive lineman for Nebraska
just grew up fucking punching,
steer in the Goddamn head,
the fucking maniacs. So, um,
the fact that he grew up in
Iowa might be a lost cause.
So I would just say try fostering
a dog. And try to just get,
get one that is cool
in chills. What if you,
if your boyfriend's active,
maybe you want something that's a little
more athletic, but like, you know,
so you can have a dog that just wants to
chill while you watch the fucking game.
I mean, that's the best. That's why I
love my dog. My dog is fucking shredded.
It makes me want to work
out. But then also, you know,
it is down to take a nap
any fucking time you want.
It's not like those sheep herd and
fucking lunatic dogs that have like add.
And if you don't give it a project, it
starts fucking eat in the door, you know?
Uh, but anyways, good luck with
that shit. Alright. Beyoncé's album.
Uh, dear Billy def jam,
my girlfriend was listening to the new
Beyonce album for a couple days straight.
I let her listen because, uh,
we usually listen to my music,
which is music she loves. Anyways, I
didn't say it's funny, I let her listen.
You know what? It's okay.
You can listen to that. Um,
I didn't say anything
for the first few days,
but then I just started getting
sick of hearing the same songs.
She understood this and did not take
offense because she's a great girl and I
don't waste my time with shitty
girlfriends who can't communicate. Dude,
I got to admit right now at this
point, you sound like, you know,
a girl's a great girl. As long as she
wants to do everything you wanted to do.
She's a great girl. I'd say
I'm sick of the two days.
I'm sick of your music and she's been
listening to your music for fucking ever.
Uh, maybe I'm reading into
this. Anyways, later that night,
we're at a bar with their friends
or with their friend who is really,
who has a really annoying name
that rhymes with small lien.
She brings up the album, the
Beyonce album and how great it is,
and my girl laughs and says, yeah, I
burnt this guy out with it pointing to me.
Her friend saw this as an opening to
regurgitate every stupid soundbite she's
read on a blog.
Apparently I'm not comfortable with women
being in a dominant position or if a
guy did what she did, I
wouldn't care. Uh, yeah,
I know this, this,
this happened when that Atlanta's
mortar set album came out and I remember
enjoying some of the music and
some woman in a bar was going like,
do you even know what the song is the
bat like? Like I should like, like a,
like I had some,
a relationship with the Atlantis and
she was yelling at me like I don't
understand it. You know what I mean?
The songs either fucking, you know,
either like the musical, you don't,
I don't give a fuck what
she's singing about. Right.
MMM. [inaudible]
at the end of the day. Yeah. If you could
fuck be fucking be singing row, row,
row your boat. If it sounds good,
I'm going to listen to it. Like,
I'm not necessarily a fan of her shit but
that one that she did with Jack White.
I liked that song cause cause the song
sounds good and I've heard it like 10
times cause Nia has been playing it and
I cannot tell you one fucking lyric in
it. I don't need, I don't even know
what it's about. Um, but anyways,
I finally had to interrupt her and explain
that while I think she's what she's
singing about is annoying.
You said it annoying is annoying.
My only complaint was that I was tired
of hearing the same song songs for three
days straight.
She wouldn't even listen ignoring me and
the words coming out of my calm mouth
dismissing logic.
I turned to my girlfriend and said how
can a girl is smart as you have such
such one dismissed.
Oh such a one diminish
dimensional friend. Yup.
She tossed what was left
of her drink on me. Wow.
This chick is way out of line. It was
a beer bottle that was almost empty.
I barely got any drops on me.
She got mad when I laughed and turned
and stomped off that I say too much.
Did I say too little? Listen, I'm not
saying you're not a dick. I think,
uh, I think you said, I think
what you said was perfect.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like to be honest with you,
yeah.
At some point your girlfriend should
have stepped in and be like, Ben,
like guys got, maybe she was guys, guys,
settle down, settle down, settle down.
Um, but whenever an album like
this comes up, I mean, she,
she realizes that that album is just
like a big fucking, isn't it? Like,
you know,
just like a big fucking, uh,
what do they call it? Trolling?
Isn't she just acting like
that happened? I mean,
I don't think she let calluses grow on
her feet and do all that shit that she
said.
She always looks like she just came from
the spa and I don't give a fuck what
that guy did. I don't think
she's interrupting that. Um,
maybe she made the help go
down and go through that,
that biblical Shit that she was talking
about. But, uh, but whatever, you know,
they got to have that fucking, you
know, not everything's for you,
but I understand if someone's like
playing an Alvin three days straight,
you'd go fucking nuts. Um, but
I think I, yeah,
I think he went too far
because you insulted your
girlfriend's girlfriend by in
a roundabout way insulting
your own girlfriend.
Um,
you know, but that you have to
understand like women like that,
like in this day and
age, like this is like,
um,
this so into that shit that you're not
going to convince them one way or the
other. That's like the type of person
that acts like an asshole and just goes,
you know, guys are intimidated by me
and no point. Are they ever examining,
examining like their own behavior.
It's like, did I tell you what guys,
when I was in Seattle,
when that woman came up in fucking
slammed her hands on the stage,
cause like the stage was up to her chin
and it scared the shit out of me cause I
couldn't see anything
because the lights were on.
I thought someone had jumped on
stage. Um, and I felt like that jolt,
like right before you're
gonna get into a fight.
And I looked down and there
was this woman, you know,
screaming at me or
whatever. And I just said,
first of all, she was standing there
forever and no, no security did anything.
And I joked, I said to the guys
in the crowd, be like, Dude,
how many times would we have
been choked out at this point?
And dragged outta here and thrown
into the, thrown into fucking traffic.
This is one of these, uh,
women privileged moments where you
can just disrupt a fucking show.
And [inaudible] standing there yelling
at me for like 30 seconds and nobody
moved to do anything.
Um,
and then finally I just said, man, can
you, can you please take your seat?
And she goes, well, I'll take my seat,
but I don't need your permission is
what she said. And it was just like,
it's like, all right, I get it.
You're a feminist. But like, you know,
you're applying it. Like in this instance,
I'm not the bad guy. You're,
you're, you're the asshole.
I know you have a vagina.
So that makes you,
this terminal victim in your fucking
world and that you can never be in the
wrong, but believe it or not, at some
point you can be the fucking asshole. And
um,
what you did was you, you remain calm,
which is the way to beat anybody in a
fucking argument is as they get heated,
you just stay calm. And
when she had nothing else,
uh,
she threw your, your drink at you and
then, and then fucking stormed off.
So it was weird you won
that argument, but uh, your,
your girlfriend and apology because uh,
you made shit weird between
her and her girlfriend and
um,
and he kind of insulted your
own girlfriend in a way.
Uh,
having said that,
I applaud you for saying that cause that's
fucking hilarious and I actually wish
I could have seen that. Cause anytime
it's those types of songs come out,
there's always set that, that type
of shit of like, uh, you know, oh,
you're just saying that because this,
you just saying that because that, and
you know, I,
I don't know it because you know what I
don't like about that shit is then you
just, you just have this built in
fucking excuse. So it's like, oh,
so you're never in the wrong. If I
call you out and say, you know, x,
Y, andZ , it's because of my
own issues. It's never you.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
that takes me back to daisy Buchanan's
in like 1990 whatever when that Atlanta
smores set fucking album came
out. Um, all right, here we go.
Bobbie boxing or porn.
Jesus Christ is a, a
fucking wide variety
on this one. Dear Bill,
I'm facing a dilemma in my life and I
was hoping to gain an outside opinion.
I'm a 20 year old male and I've
always had aspirations of becoming a
professional boxer.
However, I have a problem.
I fear that I'm addicted to sex. What?
I already don't believe this. This
is such a fucking left turn. I think.
I believe this is causing problems
in my relationship with my fiance.
I absolutely, I'm absolutely
in love with this woman.
She goes out of her way to make me
happy. Sacrifice saga, got the hiccups.
I wolf down my breakfast before this. Um,
she goes out of her way to make
me happy, sacrifice so much,
just to be with me and
also pleasures me often
rose.
Okay.
What could you just say? You have a
nice, you have a wonderful sex life.
Pleasures me often. Um,
I got a picture of you with
your head thrown back. Ah,
why would you do that to
me? You can't. All right.
The only problem is my
sexual frustration with her.
We have passionate sex
many times during the week,
but I still want it even more eventually
ending up growing angry and resentful
towards her when she doesn't want to.
Jesus do go rub one out and
later feeling like an asshole.
This brings me to ask myself,
should I just fuck for a living?
My fiance and past partners have always
complimented me on my performance in bed
and my stamina. Jesus Christ. This
guy's going hard on memorial day.
Should we have a parade for you
going up to three hours on occasions?
Okay.
I love the sport of boxing and
I've always worked toward that.
But this problem I have sometimes just
makes me want to drop everything and go
fuck the world. Any, any advice?
This is real or fake. This is great. Any
advice you have regarding this problem,
my relationship or career path will
be greatly appreciated. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Well, look, if
you're boxing, you're in great shape.
You know, I don't know if you
got the Porno Dick or not,
but you definitely got the
stamina. I'm like, dude,
you don't want to go into that world
if you have other fucking options,
you don't want to go
into that world. And um,
okay. You know that
I really,
there's very few like the people who seem
to make them the zillions of dollars,
which is still really hard to do at this
point because porno was become free,
seems to be the women.
Um,
they seem to be the ones
that can become, be a star,
just cause guys watch I
guess way more of it. Yeah.
Um,
so I would say, uh,
okay,
Jesus Christ, am I going to tell you to
go get your head kicked in or fucking
go join the dark world of
porn? Um, I would say boxing.
I would say this is what I would do if
I was you. You know, you usually say,
if you looked at, you know, something
with your fucking sex drive,
they always say, you know,
boxes right before a big fight.
They abstain from sex for
10 days. Dude, you know,
your only problem you can be coming
in, then your balls are going to be,
feel like they're fucking
through the, the, the, the,
the tarmac would avail you
call it the squared circle. Um,
yeah,
I say you keep fucking boxing.
You abstain from sex and uh,
hopefully you're good at, uh,
you're good at boxing. You know,
that is not a, that's not a fucking
good profession to just be okay at,
because you're going to be fucking, you
know, your brain's going to be mush.
Um,
why don't you try, don't you try a
the UFC at least you got a chance.
If you can tap out, you
can just get fucking get.
Let's say you don't get knocked out.
You don't take a bunch of head shots
in the UFC, but I mean you can get,
you know, an arm bar.
I'd rather have an arm bar they'd be
knocked out cause you can tap out before
they pop out. You Fuck dislocate
your elbow, you get choked out,
which sounds horrific to me,
but every professional fighter
I've ever seen is like, dude,
I'd much rather get choked
out than knocked out. Um,
you just go to sleep and then the
ref stops it. You fine. Right. Um,
I got to tell you, that's one of
the oddest questions I've ever had.
Um, I dunno dude,
but God help you. If you become
successful as a, as a boxer,
you're going to become famous and
God help your relationship then.
Um,
okay.
There's no way to jerk it out of yourself.
Go out and lay on the front lawn
like one of those sprinklers.
Just fucking, you know,
shoot all your ges out and then
get on with you fucking day.
They go do your roadwork running with
your hoodie and your timberlands on.
I don't know what to tell you,
dude. That's, that's way beyond me.
You sound like you need
a, you need a therapist.
Um,
Jesus Christ. I want to
believe that that one was true.
I don't know about that one. But anyways,
that is the podcast for this week.
Happy Memorial Day.
Everybody enjoy your day off and
I'll check on 'em on Thursday.
Yeah, that's right.
Alright, go fuck yourself.